donc votre réaction aux révélations du
monde sur la surveillance du député
thierry solère par la dgse alors qu'il
était encore candidat face à claude
guéant alors ministre de l'intérieur
manuel valls juge cette surveillance
insupportable et vous alors si c'est
vrai si c'est prouvé
parce que évidemment c'est pas des
allégations
enfin on her ne s'appuie pas uniquement
sur des allégations mais si c'est prouvé
sa porte un nom extrêmement précis ça
s'appelle une forfaiture c'est à dire la
trahison par un officier public
quelqu'un qui occupe une fonction
publique de sa fonction les services
secrets les services de sécurité ils
sont pas là pour surveiller l'adversaire
politique du ministre qui est en place
peut-être ça s'est fait dans le passé
mais en tout cas c'est c'est une
atteinte intolérable à l'idée qu'on se
fait d'une fonction et à ce stade les
béné gazarian de clogher ne vous
suffisent pas puisqu'il assure n'avoir
joué aucun rôle dans cette affaire
mais ils devront d'ailleurs au ministre
de la défense de diligenter une enquête
si la phrase que vous me citez est exact
il ne dit pas que ça n'a pas eu lieu
il parle de son rôle à l'huilerie sont
absents et on en l'espèce et il est
franchement comment imaginer que des
démener de cet ordre soit conduite
contre l'adversaire électorale du
ministre sans que le ministre d'une
manière ou d'une autre n'est tenu à le
souhaiter
même si c'est souvent des basses
manoeuvres qu'on fait faire plutôt que
on ne les fais moi en tout cas je trouve
que si c'est vrai c'est encore une fois
des histoires d'officine dans la
république
d'utilisation de des services de l'état
pour assurer la sécurité à des fins
bassement politiques
si c'est vrai c'est intolérable et c'est
une forfaiture intolérable dites-vous
comme le premier sera une forfaiture ça
vous fait jeter un jeu pas envie de vous
dire que ça vous fait jeter un nouveau
regard sur le le quinquennat nicolas
sarkozy est ce que je me trompe pas j'ai
écrit un livre sur ce qui s'est passé à
cette époque qui s'appelait abus de
pouvoir parce que il me semblait c'était
un titre à plusieurs sens mais il me
semblait qu'il y avait dans la pratique
du pouvoir
je pensais par exemple à des affaires à
la ferme tapie qui depuis a été jugé par
la justice dans le sens que j'avais
analysé à cette époque je pensais qu'il
y avait là des choses keane qui n'allait
pas et si cette dernière affaire est
prouvée alors on est encore une fois
dans ce domaine de l'abus de pouvoir
et là votre société temps des yeux mais
pas tout à fait fini ça accrédite le ca
accrédite le diagnostic que j'ai porté
depuis longtemps puis il ya une deuxième
chose c'est qu'elle est le fond de tout
ça veut dire où ça mène alors je suis un
homme du centre je n'ai jamais pensé que
la droite et la gauche n'existait pas
j'ai dit que ce clivage ne pouvait plus
être le clivage dans lequel on se
reconnaissent mais moi ce que je crois
c'est qu'il y a un projet original du
centre que ça ressemble pas et que ça
n'est pas la même chose
est ce que je puis vous rappeler une
phrase que j'avais dit il ya longtemps
lorsqu'on a créé l'ump soi disant parti
unique de la droite et du centre
à l'époque les gens disaient mais on
pense tout la même chose
et j'avais dît si on pense tous la même
chose c'est qu'on ne pense plus rien et
l'idée que indifféremment tout le monde
se retrouve sans connaître le projet
parce que ce qu'on entend ça n'a pas de
sens je veux dire ça n'a pas de
profondeur moi ce qui me manque c'est le
projet dans tout ça le projet de société
sans aller jusque là par exemple une
dizaine de réforme par exemple alors et
consensus
mais ceci est autre chose ça c'est une
méthode c'est pas du tout sur les
comptes préconise la et donc le
l'absence de fonds l'absence de projet
construit est pour moi une interrogation
orale handicap ou le handicap est une
interrogation
le ce dont j'ai besoin c'est de savoir
où l'on va et par exemple le sentiment
que il n'y aurait que l'économie et que
l'économie financière qu'il faudrait
servir qu'au fond tout le monde serait
obligée d'en passer par là
ce cette petite musique qu'on entend il
suffit de voir les soutiens en parle
toujours de monsieur mac on entend le
procès à la fois client c'est pas un
procès c'est une interrogation pour moi
ça ne correspond pas à ce que j'attends
d'en savoir ce qu'attendent des millions
de français d'accord donc nba ce cas est
donc le je pense que ce qui est très
important c'est de construire une vision
de l'avenir qu'ils apportent aux
français un peu de raisons de s'engager
quelque chose à quoi on croirait qu'il
soit un carré qui ne serait pas mais
financière et qui ne serait pas
uniquement le facteur commun comparer
d'écrire aujourd'hui d'accord avec avec
une on va dire une une
une présentation sommaire de
l'ultralibéral libéralisation du pays
j'attends que nous nous trouvions à
partir de 2017 dans un nouveau cycle
dans une nouvelle ère de la vie
politique française dans laquelle on
réponde de manière différente à toutes
les aspirations des français sur
l'éducation où on a échoué et gravement
a mon avis part par manque de réflexion
sur le fond par exemple
j'attends qu'on rompe clairement avec la
politique actuelle du gouvernement en
matière éducative aux manettes en mains
contre la réforme bricolage en
particulier j'attends une rupture
franche
j'attends que on se trouve avec une
politique qui permette de qu'une
confiance nouvelle phase créer des
contrats de travail alors que c'est à
peu près le contraire de ce qu'on est en
train de faire entend parler dans une
minute
j'attends que la france est une
proposition européenne différente de ce
que nous avions jusqu'à aujourd'hui on
va en parler tout à l'heure dans le 3e
série d'obtenir ce sont des demandes que
vous vous adressez donc ce sont des
demandes que jamais que j'adresse
priorité à tous ceux qui aimeraient
avoir la responsabilité
j'espère de porter l'alternance
dans le pays et pour moi c'est le fond
de mon engagement on n'est pas là
uniquement pour des problèmes de
personnes ont peur que les personnes ça
compte beaucoup mon élection
présidentielle mais on est là pour
changer la réalité du pays
je pense que françois hollande a
bénéficié d'un crédit qui était aussi
largement du refus de nicolas sarkozy de
la poursuite de son mandat il a
bénéficié d'un crédit
il a gaspillé ce crédit en refusant
d'aller au bout des changements et des
réformes et des pratiques c'est il en
avait la responsabilité
maintenant c'est trop tard et je ne
crois pas qu'il puisse retrouver son
crédit une nouvelle fois le gouvernement
est parti avec des intentions et on se
retrouve avec une loi qui est exactement
opposée aux intentions qui avait été
annoncé sur beaucoup de sujets mais sur
ce sujet là en particulier et je trouve
ça terrible pour pour le pour le
jugement que le gouvernement doit porter
sur lui-même pourquoi abbas est très
simple le gouvernement avait dit nous
allons alléger le travail et le rendre
plus souples étant donné que tout le
monde à peu près quelles que soient les
responsabilités et en particulier les
universitaires qui travaillent sur le
travail parce que faut quand même
prendre ce travail-là ces universitaires
il ya deux choses qui pénalise le
travail en france c'est le coût du
travail
d'un côté et c'est de l'autre côté la
rigidité des contrats de travail c'est
pour ça que 80
by % ou presque 5 % des contrats signés
sont des contrats en cdd et donc grosso
modo tout le monde avait dit les prix
nobel d'économie jean tirole les
responsables politiques j'en suis avait
dit la bonne direction s'est en effet
allégé assouplir que fait-on on alourdit
on se retrouve au bout du chemin on
alourdit et en régie d'ifi ce ce
changement de cap est pour le
gouvernement a à un symptôme
d'impuissance et de faiblesse et
d'impuissance et de faiblesse en
particulier parce que le gouvernement
vous dites est ce qu'il a répondu à la
jeunesse c'est une blague sur les
bourses c'est cette occasion non mais
parlons de ce sujet finissons avec ce
sujet c'est une blague
ce qu'on appelle paris l'organisation et
à la jeunesse
c'est une organisation qui comporte
quelques quelques milliers de militants
et qui tend à se faire passer pour le
porte parole des autres les jeunes
français cl
si si on veut bien partager avec eux un
dialogue en profondeur qu'est-ce qui est
qu'est-ce qui doit crever les yeux mais
à ce qui crève les yeux c'est qu'ils
sont au chômage et que on trouve
infiniment moins de travail chez nous
même quand on est diplômé qu'on en
trouve ailleurs on en trouve davantage
diplômés que pas diplômés mais les les
taux de chômage sont effrayants et la
manière dont on conduit cette chose va
les accentuer parce que si vous croyez
que c'est en alourdissant le céder dès
qu'on favorise le cdi vous vous mettez
le doigt dans l'oeil jusqu'à l'omoplate
alors vous avez désespérant comme penser
et c'est désespérant comme faiblesse
c'est désespérant comme incapacité à
définir un cap et à défendre ce cas
manuel valls il n'est plus le droit dans
ses bottes il est le concept beaucoup de
choses aux jeunes bon c'est quelqu'un
que j'estime donc je vais pas me joindre
au groupe de ceux qui l'accablent
même si mon jugement sur cette décision
est extrêmement sévère mais je pense
qu'il doit pas être fier de lui il doit
être content c'est pas que c'est pas la
direction qu'ils avaient tracé
ce n'est pas le courage qu'il avait
défini et c'est encore une fois un faux
semblant
quand on pense qu'on prétend défendre
les jeunes en imposant l'immobilisme
dans une situation qui les conduit au
chômage je trouve ça désespérant
nos politiques de lutte contre la
toxicomanie ne marche pas et notamment
contre le cannabis présenté à tort ou à
raison je crois plutôt à tort comme une
drogue douce
mais l'alcool aussi est une drogue et
qui n'est pas douce il suffit de voir
les addictions qui sont créées
deuxièmement je ne crois pas que la
consommation de cannabis soit anodine je
dis pas pour ceux qui fument comme ça
une cigarette de enfin le 5 juin il y en
a qui ont eu une consommation festive
modéré mais malheureusement je connais
des adolescents qui ont une consommation
qui n'est pas festive et qui est
tragique
il ya aussi comme vous savez des
consommations d'alcool chez les
adolescents qui sont pas son tragique
aussi
deuxième chose crois pas que ça soit
anodin je pense que ça a un effet
psychotrope de psychotropes dangereux
troisièmement on nous dit savent s'ils
ont le légalisons va faire baisser le
smic les trafics et les violences et on
va avoir des cités assainies je n'en
crois rien parce que les le
les ressources tirées de ces trafics
elles seront recherchés ailleurs et dans
des drogues par exemple le crack on sait
bien ça aux états unis ce violent des
drogues plus violent 800 corps et donc
et donc c'est un débat très difficile
mais je ne vais pas en tout cas qu'on
puisse le résumé sous la forme qui n est
fait par les promoteurs de cette mesure
et moi je ne suis pas favorable à la
légalisation du cannabis même le regret
pour le statu quo non je je je pense que
le que le travail de prévention n'est
pas fait et je suis pas pour le statu
quo de ce point de vue là l'europe 1
souffre de coire elle souffre d'une
espèce d'impuissance elle souffre d'un
désordre intérieur parce que les règles
adoptées par les uns ne sont pas les
mêmes que les règles adoptées par les
autres notamment en matière fiscale
c'est à dire que pour moi le combat pour
l'harmonisation fiscale
l'unification de nos règles fiscales en
tout cas dans les pays de même niveau de
développement
c'est un enjeu de première priorité et
l'europe elle souffre d'une deuxième
chose que tout ça illustre si on y
réfléchit bien c'est que on ne sait pas
qui prend les décisions qu'on prend les
décisions sur quel agenda on prend les
décisions
quels sont les quels sont les mécanismes
qui permettent de prendre les décisions
personne ne le sait y compris pas vous
de gueye même de questions et même nous
trois mois c'est à dire que verser nous
sommes parmi les plus à faire et en plus
tôt en principe non c'est inquiétant
pour tous les citoyens
nous sommes en principe a remis les plus
avertis qui savait qu'on était en train
de préparer ce texte parmi vous qui est
ce que c'est ça que d'y être plus
beaucoup plus informés que je ne le suis
parce que c'est ça que les français
rejettent dans l'union européenne
oui ce que pour moi la principale raison
du gouffre qui s'est creusé entre
l'union européenne et ses mécanismes
politiques et les citoyens de tous les
pays européens
et le mur qui fait que les citoyens ne
sont informés de rien or il est
impossible aux siècles démocratique que
des décisions majeures pour les sociétés
les citoyens soient prises sans que
personne n'en soit informé est ce que
vous saviez pas et donc c'est cette
question la centrale c'est à dire de la
2de l'ouverture de au moins de
l'information et de l'information
préalable pour que si une décision se
préparent les citoyens puissent
intervenir sur la préparation vouloir
demander du roi vous attendez quoi
finalement aujourd'hui à baja temps que
l'europe change du tout au tout
sa pratique le pnr nous manuel valls pas
l'instant c'est l'armé essentielle
contre le terrorisme on c'est une des
armes et il faut prendre toutes les
armes disponibles
il faut adopter c'est le mot que je
cherchais toutes les armes disponibles
et celle là en particulier et je ne
comprends pas alors je sais très bien
les débats qui a autour de tout ça qui
est des gens qui pensent que la
confiscation des données est utilisé
contre les libertés
moi je ne vois pas ce risque ce que je
vois c'est au contraire qu'on favorise
la plus grande atteinte à la liberté qui
est l'insécurité
au débat du secret des affaires et un
temps parle de transparence la zone
europe schizophrène oui je mais nous
parlons de transparence fiscale
moi je ne demande pas qu'on soit informé
de la manière dont les marchés se
négocie entre telle entreprise était
notre entreprise
vous voyez c'est toujours pareil on
confond tourner utilise les mots que
haas a fait un sale ming ont un
salmigondis un bull dit boulga dans
lequel personne ne reconnaît ces deux
reconnaît modèle censé voir le sens des
choses m
je demande que quand on parle ça veut
dire quelque chose et je demande que on
est des règles compréhensible par tous
les citoyens
la règle c'est que la fiscalité doit
s'appliquer à tous les agents
économiques de la même façon dans les
pays européens du même niveau de
développement